nothing's more hateful than failing to
protect the one you love there's no
justice in this world not unless we make
it
avenge them I believe men of talent of a
part to play in the war to come I will
never sit on the Iron Throne you could
help another climb those steps and take
that seat
I'm not going to stop the wheel I'm
going to break the wheel a little
monsters out somewhere drawing breath
and don't think I'm ready for what I
deserve
they'll never even find what's left of
you strip away the gold knock down the
statues
and this is what remains
the Seven Kingdoms needs ruler loved by
millions with a powerful army and the
right family name good luck finding him
who said anything about him
you
hey everybody what's up thank you
everyone that left a nice comment on my
trailer video from last night those
videos are always fun to make especially
if you have like ten cups of coffee
while you're waiting for footage to drop
and then you turn around and all of a
sudden it's there and you flip we're
also in luck because I waited just a
couple hours to make this video HBO
posted an official version so naturally
that's why I added it to the beginning
of this video so hopefully you enjoyed
that you can always just rewind the
video and just watch it on a loop if you
want so there is some really big news
george RR martin officially revealed
today no wins a winter in 2015 i know
that's a huge bummer but they are
releasing a compendium they're
collecting all the dunk and egg stories
and releasing that which is really cool
because they're at a print right now for
those that haven't read those that's the
hedge knight the sworn sword and the
mystery night they're all prequels to
what's happening in a song of ice and
fire right now so stuff that's happening
on the show stuff that's happening in
the current novels so I'd recommend you
check them out they're all short stories
they're all really cool they don't have
an official release date for that book
so it'll probably be later this year but
but I'll totally give away some copies
whenever it comes so in other news
Maisie Williams did a reddit AMA but she
didn't really go into big game of
thrones stuff just because she couldn't
do suppose it's for the movie that she
made about bullying so on to season five
trailer fun stuff so there's a couple
big questions everyone had that I can
answer right away just some things that
were clarified by having a nicer version
of the trailer so just careful for
spoilers through season 4 on the show so
yes this woman this is young sir see the
reason she pricks her finger and bleeds
is because Maggie the frog has to taste
her blood to read her future because
they included the flashback scene in the
trailer that's actually a really big
deal I didn't think they would include
flashbacks in the actual trailer this
later scene is probably Cersei and her
friend melara going to see Maggie maybe
they'll show that infamous melara seen
it was always implied in the books and
if you if you have read the books just
please use spoiler tags you want to talk
about it these things up here north of
the wall might also be at hardhome
eastwatch-by-the-sea is just one of the
other possible locations one of the
notable locations on the Eastern Shore
it does look like there's an assault on
hardhome at some point that place is
just a rundown wildling town up here on
the coast it's just beyond the haunted
forest this character here might be the
Lord of bones without his mask on or
another wildling character probably from
the same area near the shoreline this
box here that opens for Cersei most
flee from the Martel's I was kind of
wondering about that now that we have
the the sharper version of the trailer
we can see the snakehead this pendant
probably Marcella's it's probably what
insights Jamie to go to Dorne with brawn
just to make sure she's okay and as for
the Martel's in Dorne it looks like
they're giving the Aryan Martell part
actually to ol arias and yes that's a
change from the books but given what
happened to Oberon it's not a huge leap
to think that she would flip her [ __ ]
and go on the warpath so she needs to
convince Prince Doran to do something
dr. Bashir Prince Duran here cannot wait
to see him I do think we're gonna see
some aspects of the Dornish master plan
you know regardless there's lots of fan
theories about what that might be I
think the show will have its own version
of it I can't really tell from these
trailer shots even with the big HD
trailer but I'm hoping we do see lemon
trees at Sunspear it feels like
something that HBO would do they pay a
lot of attention two sets here's
Margaery and Tommen sweating sure Cersei
is going to enjoy that this shot of
Tiran and Varys could be right after
they make landfall it could be when
they're in marine and this person on the
funeral pyre here looks like Maester
Aemon up at the wall this girl here
doesn't look like one of the sand snakes
but I still think it's in Dorne I think
they're going to give some of the more
salacious eres Oakheart scenes to Jamie
and brawn these soldiers here could also
be the brazen beasts they wear masks
they're just a group that Daenerys
creates this dragon here is actually
regel now that we can actually see color
in the trailer we can actually see the D
screen looking at how big he is right
here just imagine how big dro Khan has
gotten it almost looks like ragel is
bigger than drogon was in season for
this shot of the statue falling down the
pyramid might be a replacement for what
Quentin Martell does at the end of dance
with dragons and definitely use spoiler
tags when you're talking about that
because that's a pretty big one ok so
moving on to questions here we go mad
killer asks do you think that Tyrion
will reach the nearest by the end of the
season I i think you know based on what
we saw in the trailer and based on
behind the scenes stuff I think it's
going to happen way faster than that but
not right away like it's not gonna be in
like the first episode next question
Michael asks no great joy saddens me I'm
excited to see what goes on at the wall
of this season I actually I think based
on the trailer it seems like most of the
action is going to be north of the wall
next question Alexia's why did they cut
out young Griff isn't he one of the most
important characters I would actually
say you know
based on the direction the show is
taking because they stick so closely to
what Martin tells them about the story
that it implies young Griff isn't as
important as we think he is based in the
books I know that's gonna deflate a lot
of fan theories but I don't think that
Dan and Dave would cut something out if
it was critical to the overall Song of
Ice and Fire story it's a bit of a
bummer but I mean that's just this is
the way it goes george RR martin has
splintered so many side stories that
yeah i mean not all of them are gonna be
on screen next question of fooey said
House of M so this actually wasn't so
much a question but you said house of
them all I could think about was
marvel's house of em was scarlet witch
as if ilaria sand is going to be like
Scarlet Witch and she's going to scream
no more Lannisters if one of you guys is
a really good artist I totally recommend
you do a version of that on tumblr next
question Emmy asked what about Shireen
is she gonna have a part to play I do
think she will mel sandra specifically
told them to bring her but she didn't
appear in the trailer so it's kind of
hard to tell how many scenes she's gonna
get or which episode she's going to be
in there's been a lot of rumors like
that I mean a lot of side characters
that we just don't see in the trailer
that people think we're going to be in
the season I've heard that kievan
Lannisters gonna be in but I haven't
seen any evidence of that there was
supposedly a leaked script from episode
one but I'm not going to talk about that
here just because it's all conjecture
thank you everyone for so many questions
these are always a ton of fun to do it's
gonna be a lot of fun to do these during
the season so we can kind of look at
what the show has changed from the books
it's gonna be a lot of fun and I know
it'll be a little bit weird but it'll be
fun my next game of Thrones bonus video
is probably going to be the Jon Snow
character video that I was talking about
last week i'll try to post that by next
Friday feel free to leave any requests
for specific videos that you guys really
want me to do though we still have
several weeks before the season gets
here so there's plenty of time to do a
lot of stuff congratulations to the
winners of the trailer giveaway that I
was doing Dominique Lions Dale and pick
a hand you guys both went copies of the
game of thrones telltale Game be sure to
message me on my channel for contact
details so i can get you guys emails
don't forget either my episode 1
giveaway is actually going to be extra
special i mean i do a weekly giveaway
every week anyway but when i do my
episode 1 video on April twelfth i'll be
giving away signed hardback copies of
feast for crows and dance with dragons
that's signed by george RR martin so
that's gonna be real fun i just wanted
to do an
extra special giveaway for episode 1
because it's the beginning of a brand
new season but regardless they'll still
be a weekly giveaway all you have to do
to enter those is be a subscriber and
leave a comment whenever I post the
videos so right now if you guys just
want to watch the trailer on loop all
you have to do is just click right here
and it'll just reload the trailer over
and over and over and you can click here
to watch the breakdown video that I did
last night thank you so much for
watching so let's all high five season
five almost here almost here
you